revolution annexation rebellion it's all
been happening in Ukraine and Eastern
European country that was part of the
Soviet Union until 1991 Ukraine sits
between the European Union and Russia
literally and figuratively so what's the
deal
here's a cheat sheet on the Ukraine
Russia conflict
first let's rewind to November 2013
that's when Ukraine's President Viktor
Yanukovych rejected a trade deal with
the European Union taking a bailout from
Russia instead thousands of people young
and old began protesting the move at
Kiev s Maidan square because they saw an
EU deal as key to the country's economic
future but the government cracked down
hard leading to the deaths of at least
70 Ukrainians by February 2014 Ukraine's
politicians eventually removed
Yanukovich from power and paved the way
for a new presidential election which is
how Petro poroshenko who supported the
protests was voted president in May and
that's where the story might have ended
if it weren't for two things one Ukraine
is divided between an eastern region
with close historic and cultural ties to
Russia and the rest of the country which
identifies as more Ukrainian than
anything else and to Russia does not
want to lose its influence in Ukraine
which brings us to Crimea a battleground
in the Ukraine Russia conflict that
happens to sit on an oil and gas bonanza
most Crimean speak Russian as their
native language as do many people in
eastern Ukraine and when the pro EU
protests were winding down in Kiev
pro-russian protesters began making
their voices heard in Crimea Russian
soldiers and unmarked uniforms then took
over buildings and airports in the
region Russia would eventually send
hundreds of troops into Crimea which
Ukraine called
an invasion but Crimean politicians put
separation from Ukraine up for a vote
more than 90 percent of crimeans voted
to ditch Ukraine and join Russia at
least according to officials there
Russian President Vladimir Putin
announced that Crimea was now part of
Russia but the international community
wasn't having it NATO condemned what it
called the so-called referendum held at
gunpoint and the EU end u.s. slapped
Russia with what would be just the first
round of sanctions
so what could possibly make the
situation between Russia and Ukraine any
more complicated a rebellion fuelled by
pro-russian separatists in other parts
of eastern Ukraine rebels took control
of government buildings in several
Eastern
in April and while they started out as a
ragtag group Russian nationals with
fighting experience crossed the border
to lead them according to the United
Nations meanwhile Ukraine's own forces
fought back for control at least 1,000
people died between mid April and mid
July because of the conflict many of
them civilians and 298 people died when
Malaysia Airlines flight 17 was
apparently mistakenly shot down by
rebels triggering more EU sanctions on
Russia Russia for its part repeatedly
denied sending troops and weapons over
the border despite Ukraine's claims NATO
photos and even video footage to the
contrary
that's your cheat sheet on the Ukraine
Russia conflict where do you think it
all goes from here let us know subscribe
on YouTube follow us on Twitter and like
us on Facebook